c'est très cher pour nous maintenant
c'est c'est beaucoup nous aider
la rentrée scolaire est dispendieux
cette année une conséquence du coût de
la vie qui augmente et des effets de la
pandémie sur le portefeuille plus de
1000 familles ont eu un coup de pouce
mardi et ont reçu des fournitures
scolaires
une initiative de la mission bon accueil
j'ai pas de souci je vais pas acheter le
tableau je vais acheter l'autre chose
des uniformes tout seul l'organisme une
longue liste de familles dans le besoin
les demandes est pour les effets
scolaires se sont multipliés le pc eu a
eu un effet positif dans certains cas
puis on a vu des familles qui avaient
plus besoin de nos services
mais en même temps la pandémie a été
quelque chose qui a qui est qui qui a
exigé certains autres qui avaient des
emplois précaires à venir chercher de la
sève déjà qu'ils ne sont jamais vu c'est
le même constat du côté d' opération sac
à dos qui organise d'une guignolée
d'effets scolaires depuis plus de 15 ans
aussi on se réfère à la période pré
pandémie dont une opération sac à dos
qui sera en 2019
c'est une augmentation de 119 %
l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé cette année
c'est d'outiller 7000 enfants les
demandes sont beaucoup beaucoup plus
grande que ça évidemment on n'arrive pas
à toutes les combler la facture associée
aux effets scolaires varient selon le
niveau et d'une école à l'autre mais il
est somme toute comparable aux années
précédentes la fourchette se situe
quelque part entre 50 et 100 dollars un
montant qui exclut toutefois les
dépenses pour les vêtements et les
manuels scolaires
mais il existe des trucs pour économiser
les lustres se ressentent d'année en
année il ya certains ajustements à faire
des fois on n'a pas le choix de se
procurer certains matériels mais la
réutilisation
il faut absolument aller vers ça dans
les magasins les prix sont demeurés
sensiblement les mêmes
mais certains prévoient des hausses à la
fin du mois en raison de la flambée des
coûts des conteneurs ont établi que fia
ou l'autre augmenté de 1,8 à main pour
ça si les conteneurs sur les bateaux là
qui connaît vraiment beaucoup de chocs
rationnement pour éviter de débourser
davantage
il serait donc
préférable de faire ses achats d'ici les
prochaines semaines et pour aider les
familles vulnérables à l'aube de la
rentrée scolaire donner des fournitures
en bon état permettra certainement de
combler les besoins encore plus
important cette année ici et me lemieux
radio canada montréal